we're having a baby in three weeks we
will no longer be covered by our health
insurer you want me to be a delivery guy
want you to be anything if it pays the
insurance by Tuesday congratulations you
hide what am I gonna be driving he says
girls what are the benefits play your
cards right there could be all kinds of
benefits adorable Sam the job is being
my driver
that's a ride and protection you carry a
weapon weapon no I do not carry a weapon
what about karate you know karate I'm an
architect thought she was being tortured
well I pay extra for that
hi I'm guy I'm new we're the party of
the penthouse this is a huge night we
can't be breaking in a new dude he's up
for it okay you can walk away with a
grand maybe to $2,000 you gonna have to
earn it you ready for your 15 minutes
Big Daddy
act like you're Willie dynamite that way
they feel sorry for us and they tip is
harder the most important day
learn your script I have to read this
you have to perform it you're a pimp
remember even way over my head got to
bring out that big boss fur coat wear it
Mac damn that I know was in you who is
ready to party everything you will see
is
100% my wife is having the baby too much
for me about to have a kid I don't have
a career it doesn't need you to have a
career kids just need a ride and
protection that's open
[Music]
what do i do no karate I'm an artist
[Music]